à
ma chère amy je vous présente les
hommages amicaux j'aime unicopa eh bien
monsieur dit ça vous êtes très chargé à
là où mon instrument ne vous inquiétez
pas rien n'est cassé a vachement mais si
vous me rassurez vous les gars faites
vous avec tout ce fourbi vous voulez
vous transformer en homme orchestre vous
moquez parma chers amis je viens de
faire la sphère du siècle j'ai acheté
tous ces instruments chez un brocanteur
pour une bouchée de pain et regarder son
des instruments récit mme formidable est
exceptionnel regardez enfin ce sont des
instruments très classique malgré tout
comme en classe i vous avez vu beaucoup
pour les instruments comme ça oui ajoute
si t'y attendais ap oui il ya très
longtemps chez un ami à moi à risque du
brics est un collectionneur
écoutez monsieur 19 les enfants
pourraient peut-être vous aider à
trouver leur nom à mettrait volontiers
une excellente idée ma chère amie trois
soirs oui enfin ça tu viens voilà julika
le parti nous sommes menés deux buts à
rien mais rien n'est encore perdu on
vient vite les enfants aussi d'ailleurs
yat-il bonjour monsieur du snop vous
vous êtes devenu un orchestre c'est
malin mais j'ai eu la même réflexion
c'est ça qui l'agacent ah excusez moi
même si vous ne pardonnez mon cher ami
voilà messieurs 10 nab ne sais pas le
nom des instruments qui l'a achetée
alors peut-être
1er mai certainement les enfants
venaient tous monsieur décès n'a pas
besoin de vous et vous allez nous aider
à trouver le nom les instruments de
musique que porte monsieur du snob bruit
et vous chez vous si vous connaissez le
nom de ces instruments vous n'hésitez
pas à le dire à monsieur du snav comment
s'appelle cet instrument de musique dans
les deux sens tu ne sais pas que
quelqu'un personne ne le connaît c'est
un trombone à coulisse au changement de
side et ce nombre est justement moins
que tu vas essayer d'en jouer bah écoute
un petit peu plus tard parce que
monsieur du stand on a besoin pour
l'instant passée marc gales à votre
égard
c'est une flûte une flûte traversière
que veulent ils dire mais je peux
prendre sur nous et nos enfants ce n'est
pas faux bond champions le raja d'où il
est magnifique celui ci
qu'est ce que c'est ça oui vous avez
raison les enfants c'est un cor de
chasse
celui-ci connaître mais aussi du sonar
qu'est ce que c'est que ce lycée
non c'est pas une trompette ça s'appelle
un corner vous aviez trouvé chez vous
oui parfait qu
exactement c'était à 37 ans de voici les
baguettes
s'ils disent non c'est pas facile de
donner
comme ceci qu'est ce que c'est que cet
instrument
c'est une trompette exactement c'est une
trompette de cavalerie
l'année lorsque vous en avez encore
celui-ci l' art le plus lourd celui ci
tu veut le porter alors comment
s'appelle-t-il
c'est un saxophone un saxophone ténor
voilà les atouts c'est eux c'est terminé
vous
et bien voilà j'espère que nous vous
avons rendu sais rien je remercie me
reste plus qu'à rentrer chez moi pour
travailler un petit peu voilà et les
enfants rami nous allons jouer au
football dans le dauphiné travail à quoi
musique ma chère amie un pou pas ce que
je vais vous les joies de tous ces
instruments vous savez pas que je
possède la technique du saxophone du
trombone et de la flûte à bec du céline
y aurait donc monsieur 19 voudriez vas
tu as une petite démonstration à 24 ore
que vous me donnez beaucoup
si j'avoue que j'aime tellement la
maison mais je n'oserais pas ça je vous
présente ici un bon répondre plaisir
alors qu'on peut aller juste un petit
peu voyons enchaîner car amara du soir
je vais choisir entre être humains là un
côté bien
[Musique]
bon attention kazemi way en mesurent
moins autant que moi vincent valley 1 2
3 4
mais il ya quasi n'est quasi mis en
mesure je te dis aux mesures oui alors
on recommence encore une fois j'ai enfin
un deux trois quatre
casimir croire c'est insensé tu n'y
arriveras jamais jamais vu un élève
aussi dissipé ou si peu concentré qui
dira mesure n'est pas ce que c'est que
la mesure du moins 2 3 4 oui je
m'appelle monsieur du snob alors montre
nous attend son livre une dernière - 1 2
3 4
julie
cause parce qu'ils
nous écoutent
oui oui une histoire une histoire est
bien de sharjah excellente idée j'avoue
que pour casser mais ça sera une
récréation ne s'en est pas trop longues
parce qu'il faut reprendre le travail
après un accord mais
vivent les enfants venez on va écouter
l'histoire
le son
il était une fois il ya très longtemps
un roi qui possédait qu'une forêt
magnifique il aimait à s'y promener tous
les matins avant de s'occuper des
affaires de son royaume et dans cette
forêt il aimait tout particulièrement un
arbre ils allaient s'asseoir à son pied
et il lui parlait il le contempler comme
un être humain et même les jours de
grand vent il avait l'impression qu'ils
s'élevaient de cet arbre une musique
merveilleuse
un jour un horrible orage éclata pendant
toute la nuit le roi entendu hurler la
forêt
tomber la foudre il se faisait beaucoup
de souci pour ces arbres le lendemain il
se précipita et que vit-il son arbre
foudroyé
le roi en eut une tristesse terrible
pendant des jours et des jours il ne
parla pas qu ils ne donnaient pas il ne
mangeait pas tous ces sujets étaient
très inquiets parce qu'il ne s'occupait
plus d affaires de son royaume alors son
bouffon vient et s'il ya de le distraire
mais le roi ne riez pas il lui disait
va-t-en bouffon alors le bouffon lui dit
mon à gesté
je crois avoir trouvé la possibilité de
faire revivre votre arbre
à lui dit le roi et comment et bien
votre arbre était fait d'un bois très
précieux pourquoi ne feriez vous pas
fabriqué avec un instrument de musique
une flûte par exemple est ainsi chaque
fois qu'on en jour est votre arbre à
nouveau vous parlerai vous entendrez sa
musique le roi fou de joie
accepta sitôt dit sitôt fait il fit
fabriqué par un artisan une flûte
extraordinaire tout sculpté il convoqua
le meilleur musicien de son royaume et
lui demanda joue avec cette fuite le
musicien très orgueilleux très imbu de
lui-même je lui dis majesté avec un
pareil instruments vous allez voir
il commença à vouloir jouer de la flûte
pas un sont de sortie
alors furieux du même ajuster cette
flûte a été mal faite je ne peux pas
jouer avec moi le plus grand musicien du
royaume et il s'en alla leroy rue du vin
triste
pendant des heures et des heures il
allait se promener dans la campagne et
un jour il entendit au loin une jolie
musique ils s'approchent arc et il vit à
un berger qui gardait ses moutons et qui
jouait d'un pipeau puis s'était fait
lui-même avec un roseau
alors une île et lui 20 et 10 berger
veux tu venir à ma cour et jouer avec
une flûte en majesté je ne pourrai
jamais dit le berger très humblement
tu vas jouer avec cette flûte lui dire
3 il emmena le berger dans sa cour
le berger regarde à la flûte avec
admiration avec respect on entrait
longtemps il la caresse à il lui par là
et puis il osa tout doucement
jouer et tout à coup d'une musique
extraordinaire
silva et le roi entendiez à nouveau son
arbre lui parler la campagne des fleurs
des oiseaux
et le roi fut tellement heureux qu'il
demanda au berger mais comment as tu
fait pour jouer si bien de la flûte
alors que les plus grands musiciens de
mon royaume n'y sont pas arrivés il lui
dit majesté
je n'ai rien fait j'ai simplement
écouter la flûte et c'est elle qui a
joué tout seul
et la moralité de cette histoire c'est
que même quand on est très savants même
quand on a beaucoup de technique il faut
toujours
admiré et respecté
les instruments de musique par exemple
ce qu'on fait pour que vraiment ce soit
très beau voilà c'est vraiment une très
belle histoire joly moi personnellement
je me demande si j'aurais préféré être
le roi ou le berger
oui l'histoire de julie et charmante de
ses comptes ancien petit peu démodé bon
et bien reprenons notre leçon de musique
[Applaudissements]
bon alors lequel va choisir
voyons mali une à puce aaron nom qui
mange des pommes dans une gondole 1 2 3
1 re à pois je vais choisir cet arbre là
pour mon instrument de musique un
évidement juliette franchement ne seront
peut-être pas très content que je coupe
cet arbre mais de toute façon vous avez
entendu ce que je lis a raconté dans son
histoire et puis julie a toujours raison
bon alors allons-y
attention
enfin tu es enfin julien c'est toujours
pareil il suffit que je prenne une
initiative personnelle pour que je sois
fou et que je doive arrêter ça de
dhimmitude va tout de même pas compte
mais cet arbre ministre et pourquoi pas
madame à pourquoi pas pourquoi pas parce
qu'il est beau et qu'on n'a pas pas les
apps comme ça ça ne repousse peut-être
pas un arbre ça met des visages et des
amis a repoussé mais alors pourquoi est
ce qu'on les coupe de temps en temps
vous les coupes parfois parce qu'ils
sont malades ou bien parce que ils ont
été plantés pour eux utiliser leur bois
oui mais moi je moi j'ai besoin de cet
arbre mais non casimir il n'en est pas
question mais c'est non sinon si non
pour moi tant pis je ne jouerai pas de
musique
oui je voulais couper cet arbre pour
récupérer le bois pour faire un bel
instrument musique comme là comme dans
ton conques et casimir ci n'a pas besoin
de couper un arbre la musique nous
venons à temps j'ai un cadeau pour toi
justement
regarde pas c'est très joli mais très
joli à quoi ça sert
attends ça ne se plie pas
non ça ne fait pas de bruit non plus ah
ça y est c'est pour écrire un mail
envoyé au casino viendra un nouveau
vraiment pas à temps c'est peut-être
pour aspirer comme une pie du nom non
attend peut-être en souffler un vent qui
brûla temps
[Musique]
c'est un instrument musical en caddie
non plus peut-être presque une sorte de
flûte plus exactement un pipeau je
prends le petit berger avait
et les trous alors à quoi ça sert
attends je
recommence
[Musique]
mais on reprend le travail
mais par cette masse et rabbit
[Musique]
sont mis le sang qui ont fait ça
que ce maître incontestable je crois
plutôt monsieur du stade que casimir a
bien écouté le contre démodé que j'ai
raconté tout à l'heure ah bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]